herzlich willkommen zur zdf heute live
nach einer nacht die viele
wahrscheinlich in unguter erinnerung
behalten werden denn sturmtief zähne
biss über weite teile deutschlands
gefegt wenn ihr in der nordhälfte des
landes wohnt dann habt ihr sicherlich
mitbekommen wir hoffen bei euch ist
alles ohne schäden abgegangen was leider
nicht alle behaupten können seine part
schaden hinterlassen außerdem gab es
mindestens zwei tote vielleicht sogar
drei so starb im nordrhein-westfälischen
kreis steinfurt ein mann als er mit
seinem auto gegen einen umgestürzten
baum vor auch anderswo blockierten
entwurzelte bäume etliche straßen fielen
auf häuser oder oberleitungen viele
menschen wurden von umherfliegenden
gegenständen erfasst
in nordrhein westfalen starb außerdem
möglicherweise ein dritter autofahrer
das weiß man noch nicht wir wollen
zunächst dorthin schauen wo es am
heftigsten gewütet hat an die
nordseeküste dort war ja fabian köhler
ist für uns vor ort in norddeich fabian
eine schwere bis sehr schwere sturmflut
angesagt gewesen wie heftig ist es dann
tatsächlich gekommen
ja es hat hier schon ordentlich gepustet
in der nacht der sturm hat hier so gegen
drei uhr merkbar nachgelassen
grundsätzlich muss man sagen dass die
menschen sich hier sehr gut auf den
sturm vorbereitet haben und im grunde
genommen auch das gemacht haben was sie
in den behörden oder die polizei geraten
hat die meisten sind wirklich zu hause
geblieben ich habe ja morgen mit der
feuerwehr gesprochen und der sprecher
der für den landkreis aurich zuständig
ist sagte mir dass sie allein in der
nacht bis in die frühen morgenstunden an
die 500 einsätze fahren mussten dass es
doch eine deutliche anzahl gewesen und
auch sicherlich mehr als sie so erwartet
haben sie sind vor allen dingen
ausgerückt wegen umgestürzter bäume sie
berichteten von einem baum der auch auf
ein haus gefallen ist herumfliegende
gegenstände hat die feuerwehr auch oft
raus rücken lassen dort wird von
gartenhäusern berichtet die sich gelöst
haben sollen trampoline sind die durch
die gegend geflogen
die gute nachricht hier für die region
ist haben sich keine menschen schwerer
verletzt so sagte es der
feuerwehrsprecher
und man sieht ihr hinter mir den hafen
von norddeich
gestern abend ging hier im grunde
genommen nichts mehr die fähren die hier
richtung norderney und juist staaten
sind ab dem nachmittag nicht mehr
gefahren aber schon heute morgen konnte
man erkennen dass es wieder ein bisschen
betrieb gibt gestern abend war das
gelände im vorderen bereich auch
überspült das ist mittlerweile das
wasser ist zurückgegangen und die ersten
fairen verlassen jetzt hier den hafen
auch in richtung der insel norderney
inzwischen wird dein puschel ich glaube
die fachleute sagen hund sein mikrofon
schutz wieder etwas ruhiger aber die
nacht war deutlich heftiger wie hast du
sie persönlich erlebt
ja also das war schon wirklich extrem
wir sind gestern nachmittag hier
angekommen und konnten da noch vorne am
wasser auch ein paar aufnahmen machen
und haben auch eine erste schalte
gestern nachmittag noch von dort machen
können da hat es schon ordentlich
gepustet und dann sind wir am abend hier
in unser hotel gegangen und wir stehen
auch jetzt hier gerade auf unserer
terrasse vom vom hotel im grunde
genommen nur drei meter von unserem
zimmer entfernt wo wir auch gestern
abend gestanden haben jetzt ist es hier
immer noch ordentlich stürmisch aber das
was gestern abend hier abging das war
schon wirklich extrem das habe ich auch
so noch nicht erlebt und auch wie eben
thema an das so noch nicht erlebt dass
man sich wirklich festhalten musste und
es wäre einfach zu gefährlich gewesen
weiter raus zu gehen das konnte man
schon erfahren indem man hier einfach
nur auf die terrasse gegangen ist und
wirklich zu sehen musste dass man sich
auf den beinen halten konnte das gesagt
bei dir in der region ging es ohne
verletzte ab aber etwas weiter in der
gemeinde rust da ist ein mann ums leben
gekommen
auf sehr tragische art und weise was
kannst du uns darüber berichten
ja das ist im bereich der wurster
nordseeküste passiert so heißt der
landstrich dort ich hatte mit der
polizei in cuxhaven gesprochen der mann
soll in der nacht versucht haben auf ein
stallgebäude zu klettern das hat er wohl
auch geschafft er wollte dort reparatur
arbeiten ausführen da soll der sturm
dachziegel gelöst haben so sagt es die
polizei und er hatte wohl versucht
dieses dach zu reparieren und bei diesen
arbeiten muss er durch das dach hinab
gestürzt sein und csu zehn meter tief
gefallen und dann dort auch leider
verstorben für die polizei war es
relativ schwierig da an die
unglücksstelle heranzukommen weil die
feuerwehr dieses gebäude wohl auch
sicher musste und es sieht wohl so aus
dass die feuerwehr den mann bergen muss
weil dort noch nachteile drohten
herabzustürzen
dankeschön fabian eine frage noch wie
sieht es denn auf den inseln aus die
fähren fahren ja weiterhin nicht was
weiß man über die zustand dort
ja zu den inseln ist sicherlich zu sagen
dass das gute für die inseln ist dass
der dass der sturm und der wind gestern
und in der nacht auch aus richtung
westen kam das ist eine sturm richtung
die die inseln sozusagen kennen und wo
man dort darauf eingestellt ist die
bestandsaufnahme läuft dort sicherlich
jetzt erst noch es wird sicherlich
einige durchbrüche geben aber wirklich
genaueres kann man noch nicht sagen ich
habe mit einigen leuten auf den inseln
telefoniert
die haben gesagt es war am ende so wie
man es erwarten kann es hat schwer
gestürmt und jetzt muss man einfach
gucken inwiefern die dünen und die
sanddünen gehalten haben oder eben nicht
aber die bestandsaufnahme dort läuft
noch und vor allen dingen das wetter ist
es ja weiterhin stürmisch also man muss
einfach gucken was sich über den tag
ergibt und dann muss man schauen was
dort wirklich passiert ist und am
festland kann man schon da absehen
welche schäden der sturm und auch die
flut hinterlassen
also es gibt hier sicherlich im großraum
noch gesperrte straßen durch umgestürzte
bäume es gibt auch berichte von vor
allem von baukränen die in der nacht
gesichert werden mussten die drohen
womöglich auch umzustürzen
hier in dem bereich gibt es sicherlich
schäden an gebäuden es gibt schäden
womöglich auch an pkws oder so etwas
aber die bestandsaufnahme läuft noch und
die feuerwehr sagte auch dass sie auch
den ganzen tag über noch im einsatz sein
wird davon gehen die leute zumindest aus
und sie arbeiten die einsätze jetzt nach
und nach ab und dann hat man hier ein
bisschen wohler die hoffnung dass es
über den tag ein bisschen weniger wird
aber schon der nächste sturm ist ja
vorher gesagt für sonntag und auch für
montag er soll aber nicht ganz so heftig
ausfallen und ein bisschen wind das sind
sie hier oben im norden ja auch gewöhnt
war wie an vielen dank für diese
aktuellen eindrücke du bleibst bei uns
vor ort in norddeich wo übrigens schon
der nächste regen gleich ein treffen
könnte das sagt nathalie unser
zdf-experte der natürlich die ganze zeit
auch den blick hier am monitor hat und
die wetterlage für uns beobachtet ersten
aus meteorologischer sicht ist es so
heftig gekommen wie man das erwartet
hatte ja etwa also es gab böen bis 140
kilometer pro stunde die letzte
auswertung ist noch nicht raus also es
kann auch sein dass es darüber lag ich
hatte um die 150 zumindest an einem
leuchtturm gesehen in den daten das muss
noch zuende ausgewertet werden werden
wir wahrscheinlich heute noch erfahren
ob die windgeschwindigkeiten tatsächlich
an der küste so hoch waren aber generell
hatten wir ja dann im norden vor allem
der nordhälfte sehr viel wind teilweise
auch bis in runter richtung
mittelgebirge und südlich davon sturm
und schwere sturmböen und orkanartige
böen in kilometer pro stunde sind das 80
bis 100 110 und teilweise auch 120
kilometer pro stunde also es war ein
sehr sehr ruppige
aufzug dieses sturms der sich nun jetzt
allmählich aber verabschiedet schaut man
auf die aktuelle lage das ganz große
heftige ist jetzt ja durchgezogen wie
ist die aktuelle lage letzten ja wir
können ja mal gucken was die das
vorhersagemodell gerade und siehe
anzeigt wir können ja mal auf dem und
schalten ja ich sehe gerade haben wir so
wir sehen hier dass das quasi noch
relativ viel wind im osten ist heute
nachmittag das sind eben noch sturmböen
und auch hier richtung da wo der fall
sich quasi bewegt an der nordsee das
sind auch teilweise schwere sturmböen
dabei so was passiert dann heute nacht
heute nacht wird das abflauen wir sehen
vor allem im norden wird es weniger hier
nochmal ich bewegt man
anzeiger darüber aber sonst wird es
wieder weniger schon wieder sturmböen
dass es etwa bis heute nach der fall und
auf die weiteren aussichten schauen wir
dann nachher genau und damit ist auch
die frage von rudolf schmidbauer
beantwortet dann später der uns über
facebook fragt wie es denn heute
weitergeht das klären wir natürlich
gleich für den moment es dann erstmal
herzlichen dank übrigens apropos
facebook falls ihr heute nacht etwas
erlebt hat was wir uns berichten volt
tut das gerne per e-mail über zdf heute
- live at
zdf.de in hamburg oder an der elbe bzw
hatte der deutsche wetterdienst auch
eine sehr schwere sturmflut vorausgesagt
und in hamburg erreichen wir unseren
reporter ralf zimmermann von seefahrt da
ist die elbe neben der 11 wie heftig ist
es denn nun wirklich dort gekommen
na ja es ist schon ziemlich heftig
gewesen dass muss man sagen ich stehe
auf dem hamburger fischmarkt den kennt
man weil wir immer wieder die bilder
zeigen da wird ja immer wieder
überschwemmt und schmecken noch einmal
mit der kamera nach unten da sieht man
nämlich noch den schlamm der ist dann
hier noch nicht ganz weg obwohl die
hamburger stadtreinigung die sind immer
sehr schnell die jungs und
damen der hamburger stadtreinigung und
machen sehr schnell wieder sauber
sozusagen aber das wasser hat hier also
ungefähr so hoch gestanden tatsächlich
heute wie ich groß bin und das heißt
eine sehr schwere sturmflut war ja dann
nachgebessert worden in der stadt
gestern war erstmal nur von einer
schweren sturmflut die rede und insofern
ist das wasser schon extrem hoch gewesen
aber eben nicht so hoch dass es
irgendwie bedrohlich wahr und die autos
waren glaube ich heute ausnahmsweise
auch mal alle weggefahren insgesamt war
die wetterlage aber schon heftig es gab
hier wirklich heftige orkanböen der
windstärke elf auch und das was vorher
gesagt war das ist hier in hamburg auch
mehr oder weniger so angekommen aber man
war sehr gut vorbereitet und das gute
war halt dass es nachts stattgefunden
hat dadurch waren sowieso sehr wenige
menschen unterwegs und die dann
vielleicht nicht unbedingt unterwegs
sein mussten die waren es dann auch
nicht insofern ist an personenschäden
jedenfalls aus hamburg mir im moment
nichts bekannt das ist auch deshalb eine
gute nachricht weil natürlich gerade in
den großstädten besonders vieles hier
wird gerade nochmal die kameralinse
geputzt durch wind und regen bestimmte
benetzt was rumfliegen kann in der
gegend und leute treffen kann deswegen
hat die feuerwehr in berlin zum beispiel
den ausnahmezustand ausgerufen wie sieht
das in hamburg aus
ja das können wir am besten mal fragen
den fachmann den dann würde mich hier
den sprecher der hamburger
berufsfeuerwehr
herr schneider moin moin das war eine
kurze oder gar keine nacht bei ihnen wie
schlimm kam es wie sehr in berlin ist
der ausnahmezustand ausgerufen worden
das war in hamburg ja nicht der fall
nicht doch wir haben seit mittwoch den
ausnahmezustand wir hatten ja schon
mitte der woche ein sturmtief hier und
auch hochwasser dort haben wir schon 850
einsätze abgearbeitet jetzt in der nacht
noch mal 650 der wirt der einsätze und
am vormittag sind jetzt schon wieder 200
die dazugekommen sind die stadt wird
bachmann sieht die schäden man ruft die
feuerwehr und wir sind natürlich da und
man muss ganz deutlich sagen ohne die
freiwilligen feuerwehren hier in hamburg
hätten wir das nicht geschafft ja also
ich hab jetzt ausnahme und
katastrophenzustand verwechselt was ist
denn so wichtig bei den freiwilligen
feuerwehren auch vielleicht können sie
das noch mal sagen weil es ist ja
unglaublich viele sie haben glaube ich
850 einsätze gehabt jetzt in der letzten
nacht waren dass die einsätze der
freiwilligen feuerwehr mit das waren
hauptsächlich wegräumen von ersten
bäumen und so weiter nicht ja das waren
tatsächlich wie wir sagen wetterbedingte
einsätze ist die bäume umgestürzt ist es
so umgestürzt wir hatten bauzäune wir
hatten toiletten die herum geflogen sind
und diese ganzen schäden muss natürlich
beseitigt werden wir sind 17 wochen in
hamburg von der berufsfeuerwehr und 86
freiwillige feuerwehren und die nehmen
wir natürlich für waren über mit 50 1
freiwilligen feuerwehren waren wir im
dienst zeitgleich und die haben wir
natürlich die größten schäden beseitigt
und wir sind halten uns da ein stück
weit für zurück für den brandschutz wir
hatten ja auch ein großfeuer heute nacht
das mussten wir auch noch beseitigen
haben viele menschen aus dem brennenden
haus geholt und gemeinsam haben wir
sondern hingeben kommen also die
hamburger berufsfeuerwehr ist sehr
solidarisch mit den freiwilligen
feuerwehren und will den ruhm nicht
alleine für sich in anspruch nehmen sehr
schön herr schneider vielen dank dass
sie extra hergekommen sind und
hoffentlich jetzt mal ein paar ruhige
stunden denn es soll ja noch weiter
stürmisch werden
eine frage übrigens die hamburger haben
ja eine freiburger feuerwehr ist ganz
toll im twittern also wenn man da mal
gucken will kann man bei twitter mal die
berufsfeuerwehr hamburg nachschauen da
die sind ganz toll dabei und er gehört
zum twitter team deswegen sage ich das
weil er ja diese community bei euch
versorgt sagen gerade das community ist
das sicherlich auf offene ohren und
apropos weil du gerade solidarisch
angesprochen hast christine kopp und
marion torres sagen über facebook ein
großes danke an alle helfer an alle die
ihr leben leben riskieren vielleicht
magst du das auch weiter geben dem
schließen wir uns natürlich auch gerne
an ralf du beobachtest für uns ja auch
die lage bei der deutschen bahn alle
züge sind gestoppt worden schon gestern
das macht die bahn inzwischen ja
vorsorglich und es wird auch noch ein
weilchen dauern bis die züge wieder
fahren auch wenn der wind jetzt etwas
abgeflaut ist warum ist das so was
dauert dann noch
alle züge im nördlichen teil
deutschlands muss man einschränkend
sagen also nördlich der linie
niedersachsen
sachsen anhalt
brandenburg das da ist der gesamte
fernverkehr eingestellt nach wie vor die
bahn kann auch noch nicht sagen wann
heute dort wieder fern züge verkehren
hier aus hamburg geht gar kein fernzug
gehen gar keine regionalen zugverkehr
ist extrem eingeschränkt das liegt
natürlich daran dass man jetzt die
strecken kontrollieren muss und das wird
auch getan das gesamte personal wird im
moment dazu ein gesetz tatsächlich
sicherzustellen und zu schauen wo noch
strecken unbefahrbar sind wo noch
nachgebessert werden muss damit das
ganze system dann wieder läuft die bahn
hat das ja gestern auch erklärt dass sie
gesagt haben lieber vorsorglich
einstellen und die leute nicht irgendwo
auf halber strecke stranden lassen und
sie dann dort versorgen müssen das war
ja der hauptgrund und insofern war es
heute zum beispiel am hamburger
hauptbahnhof extrem ruhig es gab dort
einen zug den man bereit gestellt hat wo
leute übernachten konnten aber das kaum
genutzt worden also das ist eigentlich
wenn man jetzt mal davon absieht dass
man eben nicht bahn fahren konnte ist
das relativ klar geregelt gewesen auch
wenn es gestern doch viele viele
menschen gab die entsetzt waren dass sie
dann zb aus dem süden kommend bis
hamburg gar nicht mehr gekommen sind am
nachmittag sondern sich dann in taxen
oder sonst irgendwie durch kämpfen
mussten um vielleicht noch in den norden
zu kommen also das war schon schwierig
hast du schon mal wann der zugverkehr
wieder anläuft das muss man heute sehen
genau das wollte ich jetzt fragen auch
was die nächsten tage angeht in soll ja
noch ein bisschen windig bleiben und
nicht nur in den kommenden stunden mehr
von osten gleich was heißt das für den
bahnverkehr hast du da informationen
schon
nein die wollen heute die bahn wird
wahrscheinlich heute mitte heute
nachmittag dazu was sagen wie gesagt da
wird jetzt erst mal geschaut wie der
stand der dinge tatsächlich ist und dann
will man sich dazu äußern die prognosen
gestern vom deutschen wetterdienst
und auch vom bundesamt für
seeschifffahrt und hydrographie waren ja
sehr genau
also es ist ziemlich genau das
eingetreten was passiert ist und
dementsprechend ist ja für morgen zwar
wieder ein sturm angesagt aber eben kein
orkan bisher muss man auch mal sehen ob
das dann wieder auswirkungen hat auch
schon am morgigen tag vorsorglich also
insofern der bahnverkehr da ist im
moment eine große unsicherheit wie es da
weitergeht ansonsten
muss man einfach bei wetter sich darauf
wetter einstellen das kann man hier aus
hamburg weiß man dass es ist sozusagen
eine lebensweisheit die vielleicht aus
hamburg noch mitgeben kann die mörders
meinen hamburger zeiten noch sehr
präsent ist vielen dank für deine
eindrücke und informationen
von westen nach osten ging es über
deutschland und so schauen auch wir über
die betroffenen gebiete jetzt weiter an
die ostsee genauer gesagt nach
warnemünde wo anne stadtfeld sich für
uns postiert hat und uns berichten kann
wie es dort aussieht bei dir also ist
seine später angekommen als in hamburg
und in ostfriesland wie ist die aktuelle
lage bei euch
ja auch hier entspannt sich die lage
jetzt so langsam der höhepunkt des
sturmtiefs war heute morgen so zwischen
5 und 6 uhr da hatte man auf hiddensee
tatsächlich die spitzen
geschwindigkeiten gemessen am leuchtturm
in dornbusch waren das 154 kilometer pro
stunde der deutsche wetterdienst hatte
daraufhin dann auch noch mal die
unwetterwarnung für mecklenburg
vorpommern verlängert bis 9 uhr die ist
jetzt aber auch aufgehoben aber
stürmisch ist es auch hier immer noch
und hast mal hast du schon der
informationen über die schäden die das
sturmtief angerichtet hat
ja grundsätzlich kann man sagen dass
insgesamt alles hier sehr glimpflich
ausgegangen ist gott sei dank niemand
ist ernsthaft verletzt worden es gibt
auch keine größeren schäden aber dennoch
war und ist die feuerwehr hier im
dauereinsatz im in mecklenburg
vorpommern die leitstellen haben uns
über 1000 einsätze gemeldet da geht es
dann hauptsächlich darum dass bäume und
äste auf
straßen auf häuser auf garagen auf autos
gekracht sind umgestürzt sind also
massiver blechschaden der hier dieses
sturmtief auch angerichtet hat aber
grundsätzlich ist sind keine menschen
verletzt worden jedenfalls nicht schwer
und auch keine größeren schäden hier
bisher die uns bekannt sind
anders als an der nordsee wo der wind ja
das wasser aufs land drückt ist es bei
euch an der ostsee genau umgekehrt da
wird das wasser weg gedrückt was
bedeutet das genau
dass durch die windrichtung wird das
meer so zu sagen oder die ostsee
sozusagen gegen das meer gedrückt bisher
gibt es deswegen bei uns an der
ostseeküste auch noch keine
sturmflutwarnung die pegelstände sind
auch noch normal aber meteorologen
berichten dass es zu einem sogenannten
badewannen effekt kommen kann also in
dem moment wo der wind wieder ein
bisschen nachlässt schwappt das wasser
dann wieder zurück und das kann dann
durchaus ein bisschen heftiger werden so
dass man die pegelstände hier absolut im
auge behalten muss gerade in den orten
wie wismar wo dann auch schon mal
schnell so parkplätze auch überlaufen
und so also das wird auf jeden fall im
auge muss im auge behalten werden und
wird sich auch im laufe des tages dann
zeigen wie stark das dann zurückkommt
also noch keine komplette entwarnung an
vielen dank auch du bleibst für uns auf
position wir schauen über den tellerrand
hinaus denn bevor der sturm deutschland
erreichte hatte er schon mit ähnlicher
wucht andere länder getroffen nämlich
großbritannien frankreich und die
benelux-staaten
mindestens sechs menschen kamen in
diesen ländern ums leben auch dort gab
es entwurzelte bäume und sturmfluten in
zehntausenden haushalten fiel der strom
aus eindrucksvolle bilder
jetzt sind wir natürlich gespannt wie
sich das ganze noch weiterentwickelt
angesprochen haben wir es jetzt immer
wieder es ist noch nicht vorbei es denn
wie wird sich der sturm in den kommenden
stunden entwickelt also es wird noch
stürmisch bleiben es sind so 70er 80er
böden sind durchaus noch drin vor allem
nach nordosten hin
und dann wird es allmählich weniger
werden aber morgen das hat mir eben
schon gesehen im süden deutschlands gibt
es dann wieder stürmische böen bis
sturmböen aber deutlich heftiger wird es
dann in der nacht auf montag und das
sollten wir uns tatsächlich mal hier
genauer angucken übrigens kaum grad auch
die die neuesten modellrechnung rein
also das sechste modell quasi von heute
morgen und da sehen wir eigentlich schon
hier in der nacht auf montag in den
frühstunden dass da schon wieder doch
ziemlich viel ziemlich viele sturmböen
verbreitet alles was ihr rot ist
stürmisch bis sturmböen und die
violetten sind teilweise orkanartige
böen und wir sehen auch die nordsee
trifft es ja doch wieder relativ stark
und auch richtung richtung ostsee ist
auch was los wir schauen uns das mal im
verlauf an ich ziehe das mal rüber man
sieht hier wie das von nordwesten zum
abend mitternacht jetzt hier diese karte
wie das dann sich weiter richtung osten
verlagert quasi also das ganze mit
dieses ganze diese diese sturm phase ist
noch nicht durch und das ist eben auch
der montag und jetzt ist natürlich das
immer so je nachdem wie das tief zieht
es ein bisschen weiter südlicher trifft
es andere teile bleibt es weiter im
norden wird hauptsächlich der norden
getroffen das ist ja quasi von heute aus
nicht so ganz genau vorhersagbar aber
was wir schon mal wissen dass das nicht
durch ist und dass da durchaus nochmal
orkanartige böen um 110 kilometer pro
stunde vor allem bei durchgehend von
pfronten also freunde kaltfronten das
ist ja dann sehr sehr ruppig damit
müssen wir nochmal rechnen und ja also
wir sind noch nicht fertig damit ab wann
ist dann ruhe ja also ich würde mich
jetzt gar nicht trauen jetzt entwarnung
zu geben weil es bleibt ja hier
weiterhin wenn ich auch dienstag ist
noch winter aber nicht mehr so heftig
ich würde sagen wir müssen das weiter
beobachten und wir sollten einfach drauf
schauen es sieht richtung ende der woche
sieht es dann definitiv ruhiger aus aber
das müssen wir noch mal tatsächlich
genau checken weil jeder modell auf
macht es anders und wir haben ja auch
gestern gesehen also bis bis zuletzt
wurden noch die prognosen angepasst bei
solchen schnell schnell ziehenden
sturmtiefs ist das halt tatsächlich so
viele tage im voraus exakt nicht
vorhersagbar man weiß es kommt ein tief
man weiß ungefähr die
windgeschwindigkeiten aber wo genau was
passiert das muss man immer sehr nah
dann betrachten deswegen auch immer
wieder der appell sich wirklich immer
wieder zu informieren in den medien auf
der seite vom deutschen wetterdienst
immer nah dran bleiben wir am sturm
damit man weiß was passiert und auch
selbst wenn die windgeschwindigkeiten
nachlassen in den wäldern auch weiterhin
danach noch ein bisschen das ist also
mit den wäldern das ist ja so dass die
ja die die bäume die umgefallen sind die
sind ja klar die liegen aber es gibt ja
einige bäume die auf andere fallen und
vielleicht angeknackst sind und da
braucht es vielleicht nur noch eine 80er
boe also 80 kilometer pro stunde aus
sturm dann fällt halt dieser baum auch
noch um und wir haben sie jetzt auch
gesehen das hält ja noch an also das mit
den wäldern würde ich jetzt einfach mal
mindestens bis mitte der woche
vielleicht ende woche einfach sein
lassen einfach mal eine wald pause und
danach kann man ja dass wieder genießen
es besser als ich tatsächlich vom baum
irgendwie treffen zu lassen dass wir
halt wirklich blöd kannst du mir
erklären wie es dazu kommt also gestern
schon die heute und in den kommenden
tagen geht es ja wirklich noch weiter
wie kommt das also wir haben derzeit
eine relativ ausgeprägte lage wir haben
jetstream ziemlich klar über deutschland
und mit diesem jetstream kommen die
tiefs heran aber sehne war schon
ziemlich speziell das ist nördlich der
azoren entstanden nördlich der azoren in
diesem bereich ist quasi das wasser
wärmer als normal derzeit also durch die
erwärmung der ozeane sind ja die ozeane
so so wärme also die die die die wärme
die überschüssige wärme die wir
produzieren mit unseren ab mit unseren
fossilen brennstoffen also mit dem
kohlendioxid was zurückbleibt mit der
wärme diese wärme geht hauptsächlich
ozean und das kann man tatsächlich
nachschauen und da sieht man dass die
temperaturen um die autoren deutlich
höher waren da hat sich dieses tief
schon aufgesaugt und wurde quasi mit
dieser wärme schon zu uns geführt und
hat auch noch mal sehr viel wärme aus
dem süden heran gesagt dagegen stand
wiederum die kalte luft die aus dem
norden kam es gab also große
temperaturgegensätze und luftdruck
gegensätze das hat das ganze noch mal
mit dem kräftigen jetstream wie bei uns
noch mal so richtig angefacht und dass
deswegen war das auch dann so intensiv
den weg von sap haben bei ihrem ja schon
mal kurz angerissen als wir gesagt haben
auch großbritannien und frankreich
benelux staaten betroffen in
großbritannien heißt das tief oder hieß
es ja anders junis klasse und darauf
beziehen sich nämlich nutzerfragen
deswegen komme ich drauf erstens warum
das bei uns überhaupt seine preis und
zweitens warum wir in deutschland
eigentlich immer andere namen haben als
es die anderen länder haben vielleicht
erklärt und ja also in deutschland kann
ich auf jeden fall sagen werden die
namen jahr an der freien universität
berlin vergeben und dort
kann man diese hochs und tiefs kaufen
also soll jetzt keine werbung sein aber
es ist halt so man kann tatsächlich
einen namen kaufen und dann bekommt das
nächste tief beziehungsweise in der
liste das nächste tief was ansteht
bekommt dann diesen namen man kann jetzt
eigentlich auch nicht sagen ich möchte
aber dass es das tief jetzt ist
sturmtief meinen namen bekommt das macht
dann tatsächlich der meteorologe vor ort
der dann die wetterkarte analysiert also
ich hab da jahrelang gearbeitet ich weiß
wie das funktioniert da sitzt der
metrologie schaut sich die karten an
früher haben sie es tatsächlich noch mit
der hand gemalt und dann gab es früher
listen die einfach vorgegeben waren die
haben sie genommen und später wurde
diese wetterbeobachtung sollte
eingestellt werden und dann haben
studenten diesen job übernommen und dann
hat man gesagt ja wie können wir denn
diese studenten eigentlich finanzieren
das können wir ja machen indem wir die
namen dann verkaufen und quasi diese
wissenschaftliche daten reihe fortsetzen
also es ist wirklich etwas einmaliges
und deswegen kann man das kaufen und
dann werden diese namen vergeben und
dementsprechend gibt es verschiedenste
namen und ein jahr sind die männer hochs
und genau das wird dann immer genau der
eine oder die andere mag sich auch
fragen ist das normal klar sturm im
februar ist es ja nichts besonderes aber
so wie wir es im moment erleben oder die
übliche frage die sich im moment ja auch
immer stellt hat das auch mit dem
klimawandel zu tun kannst du uns da noch
mal über ja ich finde diese frage ja die
wird ja immer wieder gestellt aber ich
weiß nicht ob das zeitgemäß ist weil wir
leben hier in einem veränderten klima
und natürlich wird diese zutaten diese
veränderungen auf die auf unser wetter
das hat ja auch quasi die ganze welt
anerkannt und das pariser abkommen quasi
ratifiziert und möchte sich daran halten
oder auch der weltklimarat sagt es ja
auch und im letzten bericht haben sie
auch gesagt jetzt die wetter- extreme zu
nehmen also diese erwärmung der ozeane
die erwärmung der luft das sorgt für
veränderungen der zirkulation systemen
in der atmosphäre in den weltmeeren das
ist ja alles nachweisbar und vielleicht
sollte man nicht vielleicht sollte man
das einfach akzeptieren dass es so ist
und nicht mehr nachfragen ob es der
klimawandel sowie sind im klimawandel
setzt sich auch immer weiter fort das
ist ja kein ding was ein zustand ist
also es ist ja nicht so dass wir jetzt
einen zustand erreicht haben und da
bleiben sondern das geht ja immer weiter
deswegen ist ja auch die dringlichkeit
zu handeln so groß und das haben ja alle
staaten eigentlich auch anerkannt das
wollten wir an dieser stelle nochmal
klären ersten vielen dank für seine
einschätzung und ausblicke für den
augenblick du bleibst natürlich weiter
sowie die wetter kollegen für uns heute
am ball wir schließen noch mit zwei
erfahrungsberichten die uns online
erreicht haben über youtube schreibt
hans merk hat zb es war eine laute nacht
ist klang als würde ein güterzug ums
haus rasen aber bei ihm gab es keine
schäden glück gehabt anders als bei
gerade der uns ebenfalls über youtube
schreibt dass sein baykomm mobiliar
sorgfältig demontiert wurde in münster
tut uns leid lang ist nur das baykomm
mobiliar es geht es vielleicht ja auch
noch relativ glimpflich ab wir hoffen
dass nicht noch viele schäden
auftauchten tauchen bei den berichten
die uns noch im laufe des tages
erreichen das waren die bilder die
berichte und die aussichten
informationen zum sturmtief 10 ob das in
den vergangenen stunden über deutschland
gewütet hat toll dass ihr dabei war wir
halten euch natürlich weiter auf dem
laufenden im hauptprogramm in den
nachrichten die nächsten gibt es um 12
uhr und in der zdf- heute- eppler seid
ihr immer auf dem laufenden
euch noch einen schönen tag kommt sicher
durch die nächsten stunden und tage